Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have previously talked about a technique
that used a deep neural network to transfer
the artistic style of a painting to an arbitrary
image, for instance, to a photograph.
As always, if you're not familiar with some
of these terms, we have discussed them in
previous episodes, and links are available
in the description box, make sure to check
them out!
Style transfer is possible on still images.
As there is currently no technique to apply
this to videos, it is hopefully abundantly
clear that a lot of potential still lies dormant
inside. But can we apply this artistic style
transfer to videos? Would it work if we would
simply try? For an experienced researcher,
it is flagrantly obvious that it's an understatement
to say that that it wouldn't work. It would
fail in a spectacular manner, as you can see here.
But with this technique, it apparently works
quite well.
To be frank, the results look gorgeous. So
how does it work?
Now, don't be afraid, you'll be presented
with a concise, but deliberately obscure statement:
This technique preserves temporal coherence
when applying the artistic style by incorporating
the optical flow of the input video.
Now, the only question is what temporal coherence
and optical flow means.
Temporal coherence is a term that was used
by physicists to describe, for instance, how
the behavior of a wave of light changes, or
stays the same if we observe it at different
times. In computer graphics, it is also an
important term because oftentimes, we have
techniques that we can apply to one image,
but not necessarily to a video, because the
behavior of the technique changes drastically
from frame to frame, introducing a disturbing
flickering effect that you can see in this
video here.
We have the same if we do the artistic style
transfer, because there is no communication
between the individual images of the video.
The technique has no idea that most of the
time we're looking at the same things, and
if so, the artistic style would have to be
applied the same way over and over to these
regions. We are clearly lacking temporal coherence.
Now, onto optical flows. Imagine a flying
drone that takes a series of photographs while
hovering and looking around above us. To write
sophisticated navigation algorithms, the drone
would have to know which object is which across
many of these photographs. If we have slightly
turned, most of what we see is the same, and
only a small part of the new image is new
information. But the computer doesn't know
that, as all it sees is a bunch of pixels.
Optical flow algorithms help us achieving
this by describing the possible motions that
give us photograph B from photograph A. In
this application, what this means is that
there is some inter-frame communication, the
algorithm will know that if I colored this
person this way a moment ago, I cannot drastically
change the style of that region on a whim.
It is now easy to see why naively applying
such techniques to many individual frames
would be a flippant attempt to create beautiful,
smooth looking videos.
So now, it hopefully makes a bit more sense:
This technique preserves temporal coherence
when applying the artistic style by incorporating
the optical flow of the input video.
Such great progress in so little time. Loving it.
Last time I've mentioned Kram from the comments
section, and this time, I'd like to commend
Relatedgiraffe for his insightful comments.
Thanks for being around and I've definitely
learned from you Fellow Scholars! I am really
loving the respectful and quality discussions
that take place in the comments section, and
it is really cool that we can both learn from
each other.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!